credit suisse is facing allegations that
it has been handling dirty money for
decades an investigation led by german
daily the suit deutsche taitung has
revealed that switzerland's second
biggest lender knowingly managed
hundreds of millions of dollars for
suspected war criminals corrupt
autocrats and drug dealers that's
according to an investigation by a
consortium of over 40 million
organizations worldwide the swiss bank
says it rejects the insinuations about
its purported practices
talk about that now with dw business uh
rob watts is joining me in the studio uh
rob what more can you tell us about that
data leak yeah so we've had the panama
papers the paradise papers the pandora
papers well now we have what people are
calling the swiss secrets and this is
data relating to 30 000 clients of the
big swiss lender and the accounts in
which they held some 100 billion euros
around 90. uh 100 billion dollars even
around 90 billion euros and all of this
information has been handed over by a
whistleblower to deutsche zaitung as you
said the whistleblower we don't know if
it's an individual or a group but they
have said that they're doing this
because they want to expose the
immorality of the swiss banking secrecy
laws and that those merely serve as a
figly for fig leaf that they've wanted
to remove here and we've had dozens of
media organizations going over these
documents over recent months and they
say they've uncovered all kinds of links
to criminal activity people who hold
these accounts being linked to for
example there's a there's a human
trafficker in the philippines who had an
account with uh
credit suisse there's the former boss of
the hong kong stock exchange who was
found to have been accepting bribes to
allow companies to list on the stock
exchange he was able to set up a credit
suisse account some 10 years after being
convicted of that and going to a high
security prison but he was able to keep
apparently tens of millions of uh
dollars in this account there's other
criminal activity there's money
laundering there's
corrupt politicians even an egyptian
billionaire who tried to arrange to have
his girlfriend murdered all these people
who were able to set up accounts or
kind
maintain
accounts
that uh one should be proud of what
critics are saying about it well credit
suisse uh
says that it can't comment on any of
these individual cases precisely because
of those very secretive swiss banking
laws but it does say that it rejects
allegations and inferences about his
business practices
from this leak it says that the
information is very selective and also
that it's been taken out of context and
it also comes from
over a very long period you know dating
back as far as the 1940s and credit
suisse says well that you know back back
then laws are very different practices
are very different and people expected
different things from financial
organizations but we have to point out
that more than half of these bank
accounts were set up since the turn of
the millennium so they're not so
historic so very briefly rob what's that
doing to credit suisse reputation
well it's doing it no good and it
couldn't be coming at a worse time
really it had a terrible 2021 it was
involved in all sorts of controversies
not least the collapse of the green seal
capital um supply chain financing group
and also the archeagos capital it's
recently very recently lost its chairman
because of
he was found to have been
getting round covered restrictions so
it's coming at a very bad time and it's
yet another discrediting of credit
suisse and i seem to be used to trouble
by now rob watts from tw business thank
you so much
you